lisa you are the only person i can think
of who has come out of the pandemic
with more jobs than when they went into
the pandemic and you already had a ton
of jobs i mean
you launched the podcast now you're
about to launch two shows
talk to me about how overserved came to
be where did this idea come from
well free shows actually because peacock
announced vanderpump dogs rescue as well
um i've just been very busy because i'm
a very
kind of proactive type of person and
it's um
you know i'm always passionate about
something so
pandora and jason who live around the
corner from us were quarantining with us
it was just the four of us and we were
cooking
we were decorating tables and we were
having fun and i just thought
wow you know wouldn't it be fun to do
something documenting all of this and
then
the production companies that i work
with they said you know i think we could
do something
at your house so i'm thinking well what
you know
and then i thought why didn't they just
film the thing that we love to do
then they said what about turning it
into a talk show having guests
i like it you have things rich people do
that i wasn't even aware of
each soiree i will create a one time
only event with a unique
theme i feel like i'm in a fairy tale
this was a fun part
just the same as um you know having my
podcast
you can literally say i want to meet
that person they'll come to you and say
well
who would you want first so we really
thought about it
came up with a few names vivica fox was
just like well
who's in the first episode i'm like
she's so glamorous but she's also a
butt kicking woman you know i want her i
had no
idea whether she would say yes and i
knew lance would say yes because he's my
best friend and if he didn't i'd
smack him right then you would pick his
butt
yeah exactly so and i think they
met briefly and then michael churchill
who's very funny he's lost his husband
and then they everybody came to play
bryce everybody's been
you know locked up just it had such a
feel good factor
and i didn't want to do anything with
any negativity
or you know even myself the last three
years
i went through a very very you know
difficult emotional um kind of
challenging times for me losing my
brother and then my mother and then
jiggy died
you know so just everything was very
important to me was suddenly taken away
and then
having all our restaurants closed down
so i was very productive
i am writing a book i spent a lot of
time writing my book
i did my podcast and then we decided to
do
over served and it was just a blast you
get some of my favorite people on the
show you get trixie mattel to come to
villarreal and you get the
bros trixie belongs to me who else is
trixie i love we have such a great
relationship who
i am who else do you love uh i love the
de bros heather and terry oh yeah yeah
they're on too they were great they were
a real laugh
everybody was just so happy to be there
and you know and some were sober some
people were
you know like well that was my next
question is who lived up to the title
the most who was the most overserved
guest
wow um it might be michael in that first
episode
yeah michael probably took that crown
and he was just very excited and he's
very funny
he invokes lisa rina's name how do you
think she's gonna
react to her name coming up on over
served oh my god i don't even care
he just said team winner for a joke you
know because
but um yeah that was the second of it
you know
um it was just it was so much fun bryce
i do have to ask if you had to invite
someone from the season nine cast of
housewives to a dinner party who would
it be if i
had to uh it'd probably be one of
from the cast
oh stop uh if i had to who would it be
i don't know help me out or would you
rather here i'll i'll phrase the
question in a different way would you
rather
never throw a dinner party again or have
to host the season nine cast of
housewives
well the whole cast the whole cast oh no
that would never happen
ever you would give up entertaining to
avoid that
yes because you know it got too mean and
coming at me and yelling at me and
accusing me is
sure yeah that's what i'm going to do
i'm going to radar online to give a
story said no whatever
they still make digs at you lisa renner
not to bring her name back up
even just post it again about the tax
thing i i don't really mention them and
it's not because i'm trying to avoid it
because i don't really think about them
the lion doesn't
care what the sheep are doing you've
moved on
well i have i mean i it was great for me
and i had a great time but when they
were so mean i just
wanted to walk away from it but i i just
don't spend any time
talking about honestly bryce i haven't
watched the show since
i don't hold any resentment if they
were that mean then they had a reason
for doing it
and good luck to them i you know i'm
going on vanderpump rules you know will
live on i shouldn't say that but you
know it's uh
it's been a hell of a journey i mean
to do my podcast to run the restaurants
the vanderpump dog rescue has taken
so much to keep that going because
rescue never stops you know
right so uh we tried everything we could
the new show about that's amazing um
[Music]
yeah it's really beautiful it's really
beautiful
and pooch perfect was just a blast for
me release the house
get ready to beat bow wow this is
incredible to do a
a show a competition show about dogs
back to me is like a gift
and to get to hang out with rebel wilson
oh yeah
her and i are really good i just made a
lot of great friends
and rebel she was great she really was
but
who's perfect with our business being
you know shut down i needed to work
i needed to do something because we're
also trying to you know most restaurants
even with the ppp couldn't survive it
right because of the rents and the
insurances and all those things
you opted to close the leblanc correct
well the lease was up and so we just
closed through kobe we were going to
reopen
but then you know um
by the time the indoor dining comes
around the leafs would have you know
been finished
so but a lot of our friends didn't
survive it you know the restaurant 10
000 restaurants were closed down so yeah
right
sir has been back open with limited
capacity what are the plans for pump and
tom tom are they opening soon
pump is opening on wednesday saint
patrick's day
um and that's gonna be fun a lot of
people have been asking for pump
to be open and then tom tom will follow
but i would like to see
the capacity of indoor you know step it
up a bit because
you don't want to open and be losing
money it's been hard enough to keep it
going as it is right
yes oh you're rich i'm a working woman
you know i can't afford to keep four
restaurants going
paying the rents paying all the
insurance which are a fortune
for a year with nothing coming in so you
know it's been tough but
we were very very careful you know i can
only imagine vanderpump rules will be
soon to start i would hope filming i
would hope by the summer
are what are the plans when will we pick
back up with those people
i'm not allowed to say anything until
bravo announce it
if they announce it you know the game
with that
but there's always a lot of stories
because it's legitimately
a restaurant with a lot of young people
we've lost a couple of people along the
way unfortunately
but there's still a lot of people that
the audience know
and love um that are still involved
in well i feel like a lot of life for
these people has happened
in this last year even just this week
lala is a mom
now yes last night
yes or was it early this morning i'm not
sure i think it was early this morning
yeah i guess what do you say to viewers
who feel like they're maybe gonna miss
out on these milestones for these people
they've spent
you know seven eight years with well
you might see you might see little
glimpses of it
um i think people will just be glad to
see them back
you know i love lala i think yeah she
was naughty and she got it wrong
sometimes but that's what vanderpump
rules is and that's what life is
it's about you know they were young and
they were growing up and they were
finding their way
and and but she's just such a lovely
girl you're going to see her on over
served actually
lalala is she the only vanderpump
rules kid who comes over there might be
one more
i haven't really seen any of them i've
seen tom schwartz
but i really haven't seen any of them i
i hear
you know and i speak to them but um
i haven't seen i haven't seen anybody
until just recently
uh well i gotta wrap up here but i do
wanna ask about the book because you
teased it on twitter you teased it
earlier in this interview what is the
concept is it a tell-all is it a memoir
is it a how-to guide
bryce how could it be a tell-all i've
told you everything anyway
because you are a woman with who's lived
a thousand lives with a thousand stories
so i can only imagine there's a lot we
don't know lisa well there's
there's a lot about uh my
experiences i have written thousands and
thousands and thousands of words
i'm trying to write a book that i the
book
i would like to have read when i was
younger so just to
really it's a motivational book but it's
it's also it has a lot of stories in
where i think i
went wrong or i could have done this and
what i've learned
from my mistakes uh things that have
scared me in the past that shouldn't
have it's gonna be a lot
about that but i love writing so yeah
i i don't know when that's coming out i
really need to just finish that off
in the next few weeks you you've got
you've kept busy i can't believe how
many things you've picked up during this
time but i also can't believe it because
that's the kind of person
and and a big shout out and thank you to
everybody at vanderpump dogs because
rescue never stops
and with everybody you know it's
it was difficult and we have hundreds of
dogs you know in china that pulled off
the meat truck
so it was difficult and a lot of people
booked me on cameo i think i did 800
cameos
and all that money went to the
vanderpump dog foundation so that you
know that
really really helped keep us afloat
you